[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 24
janvier avec quintet jacques galloy
interroge votre capacité à vivre et en
paix ensemble et en paix cinq danseurs
explorant l'union et la désunion des
êtres la chorégraphe présente sa
création au prisme le 30 janvier qu'il
soit d'apparat ou traditionnelles le
costume traverse les époques
l'exposition résonances elle encourt le
place comme andreu d'art et accueille
six artistes quatre heures pour plonger
dans la vie de l'école de musique et de
danse de trappes ce vendredi elle
participe à la nuit des conservatoires
chorale démonstrations et expositions
sont au programme cinq danseurs sur
scène pour parler de l'union et de la
séparation la création 2010 est de
jeunes gallois se nomme quintet et la
chorégraphe est avec nous en plateau
bonjour le jeu alors pour ceux création
vous vous interrogez sur la capacité à
vivre ensemble et en paix ce que j'ai
dans le titre exactement c'est ça c'est
je pense l'urgence aujourd'hui quand on
voit tout ce qui se passe dans le monde
et même dans notre petit cercle que ce
soit dans les serres de la famille de
deux du groupe
l'harmonie c'est de plus en plus dur à
trouver
j'ai l'impression la légaux prend une
place tellement énorme
aujourd'hui dans notre société que les
coûte évidemment s'épuise et pour moi
c'était une évidence de traiter cette
thématique là sur cette pièce à 5
du coup quintet à face donc c'est un bon
centre dans un groupe assez restreint
encore pour le moment oui oui parce que
parce que déjà 5 c'est beaucoup
finalement on se rend compte que ces
cinq ego ces cinq personnalités ces cinq
corps et
la première fois que vous créez pour 5,1
jusqu'à présent étiez à solo duo trio
solos duos trios exactement et puis en
fait assez la cinquième pièce que je
crée et puis donc voilà j'ai envie de
dalé le chiffre file est plein de choses
qui revenait le chiffre 5
donc je me suis dit allez quintet nous
par sur sa de vivre ensemble ça vous
marque et dans plusieurs de vos
créations et celui-là quintet ce serait
presque une continuité d'un duo fait en
2016 acté sa belle compas compact
compact et qui travaille sur le contact
extrême voilà où là j'ai imaginé en fait
j'ai littéralement un briquet de corps
l'un dans l'autre et écrit du coup pour
quatre bras quatre jambes de tête et
j'ai juste imaginer une situation
extrême de sur contact de sueur
communication pour mettre en avant le
fait que les coûte est nécessaire pour
qu'on avance ensemble que l'harmonie
puisse se crée par l' écoute par comment
je considère l'autre quelle place je
laisse aux corps de l'autre donc c'est
pour ça que j'avais imaginé un espace
dans lequel les plus de place entre ces
deux corps donc c'est presque plus de
lors d'une performance aussi technique
très impressionnant imparable
c'est ça tout le nom de la pièce on ne
se sépare pas et d'ailleurs c'est toute
la dramaturgie c'est que toutes les
étapes que traversent de corps pour
trouver un moyen de se séparer
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans le
quintette où il ya parfois de la
distance cette fois alors parler d'union
et de séparation voilà exactement
justement je voulais
traiter la même le même la même
thématique mais sous un autre angle
donc il ya très peu de contacts en fait
finalement dans quintet il y en a
évidemment mais très peu c'est pas là
que ce central de la pièce
l'axé central il est sur l'écriture qui
est basée sur l'aspect cyclique du
comportement humain qui est de rentrer
en harmonie et ceux d harmoniser
d'horaire entre un d'harmonie de ce gros
d harmoniser et donc je me suis inspiré
du phasing qui est un procédé de
composition musicale qui a été créée
dans les années 60 par steve rage et qui
est très simple en fait mais très
géniale dans sa simplicité ces sondes
est simplement différente polyrythmie
qui très lentement dans le temps se
décale donc on ne se rend pas compte que
les choses se décale mais tout se
disloque et puis au bout d'un certain
temps tout re rentrer en phase et cetera
donc le voyage un peu comme un poumon
qui se contracte et qui se décontracte
très lentement ce que j'imaginais qu'il
ya une offre très n'émettrait n'a pas
alors oui tout est très très écrit
évidemment parce que ça demande de la
précision
si on veut que ce soit lisible de
l'extérieur fin du profil du spectateur
et c'est ce qui me faisait vibrer aussi
ces deux
enfin dans toutes les pièces j'aime
j'aime beaucoup écrire avec une grande
précision et une grande des grands
détails intégrant détail beaucoup de
détails c'est je pense ce qui donne
matière apprécié pièce chorégraphique
quand c'est rempli de détails parfois
trop où me le reproche aussi capreau de
choses outre au 2 mai mais voilà donc je
me suis inspiré de ceux de cette notion
là le phasing pour l'appliquer à une
écriture chorégraphique est ce qu'on
retrouve aux influences que vous n'êtes
du pop voulait même du break
pourquoi précisément où est-ce qu'on le
retrouve encore vous laissez plus vers
le contemporain maintenant après cinq
créations
alors on quand on regarde quintet ces
cantons gardent même les pièces
précédentes ne peut pas dire que ce sont
des pièces hip hop pas du tout et je me
revendique pas du tout comme une
chorégraphe hip hop je dis que je viens
de là ça a été mon porte de la
fluorescence exactement ma technique
vient du hip hop parce que je n'ai pas
non plus a pris d'autres techniques mais
mais on sent quand même l'énergie la
qualité de mouvement
oui ça c'est vraiment ce que j'ai gardée
de vie pour une énergie très dynamique
très très incisive mais ça reste
contemporain parce que c'est de la
création
donc dès lors qu'on est dans la
recherche et dans des choses qu'on
trouve de nouveau dans alan et qui sont
pas ce qu'on a vu auparavant
donc ça devient contemporain par
définition mais voilà j'en avais parlé
vite fait tout à l'heure le fuzzing ce
que justement où la musique
questionné par alexandre bouvier
grégoire c'est non elle a une place
importante ça rythme tout autre
éclatement la musique est aussi
importante que ce qui se passe
chorégraphique dans son plateau parce
qu'elles donnent déjà du sens à tout ce
qui se passe dans plateau elle donne la
tonalité elle donne la rapidité elle
donne tout l'ambiance est spectateurs
complètement
voilà qui est tout un travail de
sonorisation dans l'espace qui qui
englobe la mouvance de ce qui se passe
sur le plateau et
et en plus de ça et tout un travail de
projections vidéo qui sert en tant que
lumière sur le plateau par en tant que
film projeté sur le plateau mais
vraiment de des manières différentes
d'éclairer le plateau par des
vidéoprojecteurs et pas seulement pour
attirer l'oeil d'autres manières aussi
peut-être
voilà ils peuvent suivre aussi tout ce
qui se passe sur plateau enfin
j'aimerais vraiment voir le spectacle
pour ce spectacle là il a lieu le mardi
30 janvier merci j'ai eu la loi d'être
venu en plateau alors vous serez
vous-même sur scène le 30 janvier avec
vos quatre danseurs et le début de la
représentation a lieu à 20h30 et
quelques jours avant vous on est
toujours aux prises mais il y aura de la
musique cette fois un duo de jazz as
composé du trompettiste paolo fresu et
du pianiste omar sosa ils vont
interpréter les titres de leur deuxième
album et ross avec une complice natacha
atlas regarder
[Musique]
les
on reste à elancourt on parle le costume
il peut être déguisements masques ou
encore à part à la ferme du mousseau
exposé depuis le 19 janvier des heurts
qui interroge cette notion du costume
des habits traditionnels qui deviennent
des performances ou encore des oeuvres
d'art regarder
[Musique]
des ébauches des croquis le point de
départ de la conception du costume qu'il
soit d'apparat ou traditionnels il est
au coeur de l'exposition résonances des
longs cours on est vraiment sur cette
idée là de quelque chose que l'on porte
sur soi mais que l'on porte devant un
public 1 dans l'idée de costumes ya
vraiment l'idée d'être en spectacle même
pour traverser la rue éventuellement
voilà ça dépend si on envisage cette
traversée de la rue comme une
performance mais pourquoi pas
des costumes résolument contemporain ces
artistes franciliens sont exposés
six femmes plasticienne et costumière
mais aussi des travaux d'élèves ceux de
l'école d'arts plastiques de la commune
j'ai souhaité les faire travailler eux
aussi sur cette notion de costumes
justement on a beaucoup travaillé déjà
sur la différence entre le costume labit
le vêtement et puis on a expérimenté
comme matière le papier on a essayé de
voir un petit peu tout ce qu'on pouvait
faire avec du papier et ils ont
découvert des choses incroyables de la
peinture à la sculpture résonance emmène
sur les podiums de défilés de mode ou
dans le rapport vêtements peau et place
le costume dans l'annuaire crayon et
pastel ce sont les outils de françois
bonnel cette artiste installée à saint
germain en laye dévoile son travail dans
l'exposition pastel à l'hôtel de ville
de villepreux jusqu'à la mi-février
licorne nicolas kirillovitch pour les
images
des tableaux précis et intimiste des
visages marqués par le temps des
portraits serrés ou les expressions ne
peuvent être ignorées une inspiration
pour françois bonnel je me les explique
pas exactement je crois que c'est
vraiment un travail sur fait peut-être
parce que le visage exprime renvoi
quelque chose qui a qui touche à
l'universel et puis on retrouve dans
dans les regards dans les reflets dans
les yeux dans des expressions dans les
dents des manières de regarder soit
regardé ailleurs ou au contraire de
s'adresser aux spectateurs il ya tout un
tas de choses qui peuvent justement à la
fois qui me touchent moi et qui peuvent
peut-être aussi toucher le spectateur
des oeuvres à connotation religieuse ou
le sentiment transparaît les amateurs
d'art auront peut être une impression de
déjà vu
françois bonnel s'inspire de tableau
datant des xviie et 19e siècles ribera
van dyck ou jordan ou presque
donc il s'agit en fait d'une démarche
qui est à la fois je dirais à ses
documentaires puisque je suis très très
attaché au détail ont rendu justement
des effets que que l'on retrouve dans
ses tableaux en même temps c'est un vrai
travail d'interprétation puisqu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un simple copier coller
mais plutôt encore une fois d'une d'une
manière de revisiter des oeuvres du
passé qui me touche particulièrement
françois bonnel donne une seconde vie
pour ses tableaux un nouveau regard
qu'elles soient faites au pastel ou
crayons une cinquantaine d'oeuvres est
exposé à guyancourt il se prépare un
rendez vous original l'artiste yann
alegre la ferme de bel ébat et la
commune collecte vos rêves
ils vous demandent de confier vos rêves
de la manière la plus brève possible
sans commentaire ou analyse la collecte
se fait par mail celle que vous voyez à
l'écran ou du tout dans une boîte à
rêves présente notamment dans les
maisons de quartier
yoanna lavabre le directeur de
l'établissement culturel nous en dit un
peu plus alors leurs rêves n'ont pas
leurs espérances mais vraiment les rêves
qui ont traversé agiter leur nuit on
leur demande de nous envoyer leurs rêves
par écrit ou de nous les envoyer à
l'oral et ça fera l'objet non pas d'un
spectacle d'une exposition mais d'une
performance un peu entre les deux à la
salle d'exposition de guyancourt où les
rêves seront restitués de manière sonore
avec un accompagnement musical et
lumineux et on continue cette culture en
partant attrape le vendredi 26 janvier
c'est la nuit des conservatoires et de
nombreux établissements ouvrent leurs
portes dans toute la france sur saint
quentin en yvelines un petit nouveau se
joint à la manifestation
l'école de musique et de danse deux
trappes nous a rejoint plateau sa
directrice florence méga bonjour bonjour
alors la nuit commence à 17 heures elle
commence à 17 heures et elle se termine
certainement vers 23 heures et se
prolongera le lendemain nous avons pris
la décision de faire une nuit des
conservatoires prolonger le samedi avec
notre événement phare tempo pour avoir
voilà un week-end festif convivial qui
puisse accueillir le public et qui
viennent découvrir en fait tout ce que
l'on peut proposer au sein de l'école de
musique et de danse
il y aura le vendredi en premier accueil
vers 19h15 ne chorale d'enfants qui fera
un petit peu l'ouverture du vernissage
de samuel la ligue en puisque maintenant
l'école de musique et de danse accueille
des expositions jusqu'à donner des
indices sur la programmation
mais d'une manière générale d'abord
participer à 7 des conservatoires ce
sont quoi des portes ouvertes ça vous
permet vraiment de fallope sûr j'avais
vraiment le l'envi de comment dire de
participer à cette à ces deux soirées
parce que je trouve que l'idée d'être
sur un événement national où il ya une
dynamique et une synergie on sait que ce
soir là on est tous présents qu'on met
en évidence le
les talents de nos élèves de nos
enseignants et il me semblait que
c'était quelque chose d'assez stimulant
donc on va voir c'est la première et
donc nous verrons effectivement voilà
comment ça prend sont surtout nous voilà
si on fixe des places nous avons pris la
décision de petites pièces qui vont
s'ajuster comme apple ça va permettre
justement aux enfants peut-être d'être
en contact avec des adultes avec des
adolescents de passer des arts
plastiques
nous avons aussi une intervention
théâtre / une lecture d'attali de racine
qui sera complété par la chorale de
l'école et donc toutes ces petites
choses vont venir s'ajuster avec des
portes ouvertes où le public pourra se
balader dans l'école dans l'école qui
est un lieu absolument magnifique
j'ai souvent ça montre aussi que le
conservateur c'est pour tout le monde ah
c'est ouvert à tout le monde et c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on essaie de défendre
avec d'autres collègues directeurs où
qu'ils se trouvent où qu'elles se
trouvent puisqu'il ya quand même
quelques femmes sur voilà sur tout le
territoire français c'est de vraiment
faire comprendre que un conservatoire
une école de musique
une association dédiée à l'enseignement
artistique ce sont des lieux qui sont
ouverts à tous il faut juste oser
franchir le pas de la porte et puis
voilà posé des questions venir découvrir
et puis surtout se faire plaisir je
pense que c'est le plus important que
dans votre conservatoire dans votre
école de musique et de danse c'est quand
même 500 élèves alors est maintenant
propos voilà en musique et danse nous
avons 500 élèves
répartis en danse en musique classique
et musiques actuelles nous accueillons
les arts plastiques et aussi des
ateliers théâtre donc ça fait plus de
550 personnes en tout cas élèves
voilà qui naviguent dans ce beau navire
et je suis assez ravi de pouvoir les
emmener dans cette nouvelle aventure de
la nuit des conservatoires et pour
certains c'est peut-être même la
première abbas a certainement la
personne de georges et urbain par
exemple la petite chorale
des enfants a déjà chanté au mois de
décembre donc voilà ils ont fait leurs
premières voilà ils sont là et on se
rend compte à leur sourire et puis
surtout aussi le sourire des parents
quand on regarde comme ça il ya voilà on
éprouve un petit plaisir de voir ce que
ça gênait en fait sur l'entourage aussi
alors vous parlez vous parliez d'une
exposition tout à l'heure celle de
samuel la ligue en ce sens notre au pied
oui qui est il peut-être parler d'un
plasticien il est en train d'en tout cas
avec cette exposition il
il explore la matière plastique qui avec
la chaleur donc il a ses petits trucs à
lui vont vos déformer le plastique et
créer des formes très original et ça a
donné l'idée au département danse de
travailler justement avec cette artiste
puisqu'à la fin de l'année il y aura un
spectacle autour d'alice au pays des
merveilles et donc voilà ces pièces en
volume à mon avis vont donner de voilà
de belles aventures chorégraphique et
artistique en mélangeant justement les
pratiques et dans la soirée on va
arriver on est où là on est à 21h cette
fois c'est un concert donné par des
professionnels oui lancastre hélios
voilà c'est un orchestre un peu
particulier il est bien entendu
composé de musiciens professionnels mais
il a aussi pour vocation d'encourager la
jeune génération qui
souvent et nouvellement diplômés de
pouvoir justement rentrée c'est se
lancer être accompagnés et je trouve que
le lien justement avec une école
voilà on génère on dire des ordinateurs
mais aussi on se rencontre bordeaux
voilà on a quelques quelques petits
élèves qui grandissent avec nous et qui
commence à aller plus loin donc voilà le
lire le lien est fait et au moment de
l'ouverture de ce concert ce sera on va
dire un orchestre éphémère
voilà qui a été de l'école qui a été mis
en place pour faire l'ouverture de ce
concert alors ce vendredi lors qu'est ce
que jouera la grande partie tas de
mozart et la sérénade pour van den bon
jack et pour découvrir un petit peu plus
de cet orchestre on regarde un extrait
alors là il joue le final de la
symphonie de tchaïkovski
[Musique]
et
la nuit des conservatoires continue donc
le samedi
vous continuez le plaisir avec impôts
divers alors ça c'est un rendez vous
annuel qui a pris bas de chez vous et
qui a pris date c'est vraiment
l'histoire de l'école et les personnes
qui auront eu l'occasion de venir la
veille auront eu la possibilité de
découvrir les différents lieux de
l'école et à tempo divers la
particularité c'est que le public va
faire un trajet va faire une
déambulation et découvrir dans
l'auditorium qui peut accueillir 200
personnes 20 minutes de danse va se
promener jusque dans la salle
d'orchestre pour toute une partie
musique classique et terminer son trajet
dans le hall de l'école pour les
musiques actuelles donc aura une vision
globale de tout ce qui peut être proposé
dans l'école et ce rendez vous là lui
est gratuit mais sur réservation au
numéro qui s'affiche et merci florence
bègue a alors pour tous retrouvés de la
programmation de la soirée d'élection de
direction le site de la commune
on change complètement de sujets ils
travaillent les guitares depuis 1995
grégoire égale les fabriquent les
réparer les restaurent leur atelier et
boutique se trouve à buc nicolas landry
pour les images le filon qu'on a
régulièrement par l'atelier ces petits
bonbons à peu près 4 à 5 par mois
cd tête fracturée cole ponçage et vernis
depuis 20 ans grégoire d'amico soigner
vos guitares passionné de musique il
devient luthier en 1995 dans un sous-sol
de pavillons il crée lui même les
instruments
alors là
je vous montre enfin compte un manche de
guitare brut
voilà donc à la base on voit que c'est
une planche voilà qu'on réalise avec la
dégonfler raboteuse on vient faire des
collages ce qui va permettre de mettre
des boîtes différents dans le dans le
manche d'insérer des bois différents ça
permet au bois de moins bouger avec les
problèmes d'hydrométrie est des guitares
sur mesure parfois très haut de gamme
pour des grands de la musique française
et internationale
charlelie couture francis cabrel laurent
voulzy ou encore mick jagger
alors voilà ce dont je t'avais parler
1la la corde obame est donc celle ci tu
vois là sa particularité c'est d'être
complètement en palissandre donc là tu
vas avoir un son un petit peu plus
encore pu médium voilà voilà entre les
deux du clac ans mais pas mal de mes
gars elle le sous sol devient très vite
trop petit tout comme l'atelier dans le
hameau de villars où à aiguilles en
cours il déménage à buc et ouvre une
boutique et c'est surtout de faire un
lieu où les gens se sentent bien voilà
huawei se sentent à l'aise pour essayer
leurs instruments avec une âme avec avec
avec on va dire une un peu de charme qui
soit pas un lieu édulcorer un peu
insipide
parce que souvent les magasins on va
dire il n'ya pas il n'y a pas vraiment
d'imaginaire voilà et nous on a mis un
peu nos tripes
ok bah je vais essayer
voix leur a fait une adresse qui
fonctionne grâce au bouche à oreille
les clients sont des fidèles ici je vous
c'est vraiment un endroit extraordinaire
il déjà il ya beaucoup de choix de deux
guitares et puis il a un savoir faire
pour ce qui est de leurs réglages en
l'occurrence c'était pour une casse
malheureusement c'est une guitare auquel
je tiens énormément que j'ai depuis que
je suis gamin puis j'ai 17 ans j'en ai
30 37 bientôt et je voulais vraiment pas
[Musique]
voilà je voulais vraiment qu'ils me la
fasse plus de vingt ans de savoir-faire
et 700 produits en boutique avec
toujours à la fin le petit mot de
circonstance joue bien salut salut bonne
musique
[Musique]
que voir cette semaine au cinéma lui
beaucoup à plusieurs rendez vous à vous
donner à vos agendas alors cette semaine
aussi 17 une pléiade de coups de coeur
c'est à dire 10 coups de coeur mais je
vais aller très vite
d'abord le festival télérama du 24 au 30
janvier
donc on vous propose cette semaine neuf
très grands films je les cite juste
rapidement mais vous pouvez tous venir
et voir les yeux fermés ce sont vraiment
de grands films pour les enfants le
grand méchant renard patients 120
maintenant par minute
le caire confidentielles évidemment tous
les films étrangers sont en vo une vie
violente
the lost city of z la villa de
guédiguian faute d'amour à voir
absolument et en avant-première razia et
deuxième coup de coeur pour un film que
je n'ai pas encore vu mais je peux le
faire les yeux fermés c'est pentagon
papers de steven spielberg
on sait son 10e film historique comme
chacun sait je vous en dirai plus
probablement la prochaine fois mais je
pense que c'est un film très intéressant
qui raconte une histoire une partie de
l'histoire politique des états unis
ça court sur quatre présidents américain
et ça raconte l'histoire de la rivalité
entre le washington post et puis un
autre grand journal américain sur fond
de guerre du vietnam donc
énième collaboration entre steven
spielberg et tom hanks
meryl streep aussi nommé pour les oscars
vous venez voir le film en vo et en vf
cette semaine aussi 17
le premier agenda et pour les tout
petits avec entremêlées les enfants sont
encouragés à dessiner librement a laissé
glisser le feutre sur le papier et ses
dessins seront la base du spectacle
sandrine monier et rémy lambert regarder
[Musique]
e
au théâtre espace coluche de plaisir on
joue théâtre classique redécouvrait
l'amour fou qui lie chimène et rodrigue
les deux héros du cid de corneille
c'est ce vendredi extraits il faut quand
même en droit de répondre à cela des
mois dont je te prie une seconde fois ce
qui te fait jugé qu'ils approuveront
choix c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]
e